let me pull up this next story
we have this tweet from talk radio 77
wabc
breaking news
palm beach authorities on alert about
armed protesters expected at mar-a-lago
and i love uh i love the comments people
are saying things like it's going to be
a bunch of guys in polo shirts khaki
shorts and sunglasses
with short trim hair and that's right
fed boys
so
i don't know if there's any developments
on this or how much this story is legit
but we did see a bunch of people out in
front of mar-a-lago protesting and
cheering for trump
and so when i see a story like this
for one
fed boys that's basically what everybody
is saying that they're gonna come out
and it's gonna
you know
what would you call it i guess a false
flag oh oh i see what you're saying yeah
yeah the feds are going to come out
pretending to be
trump supporters or something and get
rowdy yeah such as that they're going to
lure groups
who aren't part of the fed to
participate but then
maybe
there's there's the hanging threat that
the feds are going to incite violence
and then blame it on the ordinary people
they learned there
exactly that's what happened to january
6th right yeah
that he had been a plant no one really i
don't even know if that's ever been
confirmed did he used to work for the
fbi or anything i don't i don't i don't
know or care about um
to speculate on right apps because of
what they're trying to do to manipulate
that story my point is my point of this
is simple let's approach it from hey
there's a guy on camera inciting
violence you should arrest them yeah
yeah that's the target not the instead
what they're doing is they're using the
fact that people have claimed conspiracy
theory to discredit the entirety of the
right apps
was yelling like let's go to the capital
stuff
oh yeah yeah he's on video like very
busy let me tell you about about this
tactic used by leftists for a long time
what they do is
they'll get a handful of people
they
will organize a peaceful protest
so they can get mass and so everybody
come down and march and raise your fist
they they they will coordinate different
groups with their strategy
they'll say some people's job is to
obstruct so they'll convince people like
hey stand here the people don't know
what they're doing
when they go for a peaceful protest they
have no idea the plan of the organizers
the pawn has no idea that the knight is
about to move next and so what they'll
do is
they have
aggressors basically that will mix in
the crowd and incite the violence
because they want to do two things they
need the cover of a mass group to be
able to engage in advance and get away
and they also want videos of these
regular people being beaten by cops
so they will start the fight the regular
person will get hit they will then go to
their regular person and say why were
the cops hitting you what oh can you you
got to join us man that's how they
recruit that's the plan that's how the
fbi
works to perpetuate its own existence
they create the reasons that they
supposedly exist right look at the
whitmer thing yeah great example yeah
what was it like they were all
informants yeah it was like one guy that
wasn't
the poor guy just got brought in and
that's what they do they'll target the
lonely people that are isolated from
community and they'll lead them to feel
like they're part of some movement and
it's all these feds that are inviting
them into creating a problem that
requires them to be the solution and
there are a lot of people that do this
in in the corporate world too i mean
george soros gets accused of this often
right putting money toward destruction
so that he can come in and profit off
the cleanup you know there's there's a
lot there that we've seen this time and
time again part of the reason i'm so
frustrated with the fbi and their
dealings is that it's not just what
they're doing like this trump scenario
like this guy with his phone
it's also what they're not doing so in
the process of spending all of their
time sending all these agents to trump's
home they're ignoring the fact that the
current president's son we have them on
video and photo evidence instances where
the guy is dealing in incredibly illegal
activity and they're silent or larry
nassar silent that's hilarious the
gymnastics usa gymnastics i don't know
about this tell me about it yeah abusing
the girls yeah and the fbi knew about it
yeah they knew they knew about epstein
yeah they knew about epstein i mean the
examples are endless and you're
absolutely right oftentimes they they
need to boost their budget they need to
create problems so that they can
exemplify why they're needed as a
solution another example that i think is
industrial agricultural pharmaceutical
like this thing where they'll feed
people bread that's clay
sprayed with glyphosate the wheat as a
desiccant to dry it out before harvest
that makes people just like grotesquely
ill and then they create pills that will
you know treat it and then so they're
not only creating the glyphosate or
these i don't know if it's all the same
people but they're creating the
chemicals that to put on the food that
make the people sick then they make the
medicines to
it's it's it's
make people sick
yeah a lot of times they do a lot of
times the treatments make people more
sick than the diseases themselves it's
it's a terrible um
reality of of using like experimental
medicine on a population it's it's
devastating well a perfect example
recently is um that i'm not insinuating
anything youtube um but pfizer is upping
their uh
intentionality with heart issue
medicine so issues like myocarditis
pushing prescriptions that solve that
issue you make your conclusions as to
why
but yes it's this exact thing pfizer and
these big pharmaceutical companies
they're they operate by the same
playbook was it wasn't there like a
document recently
i saw some story where they basically
said we should reconsider curing
diseases do you saw
i saw that on twitter they were like we
should reconsider i can't remember where
i saw it may have been maybe it may
actually be an old story like reconsider
i remember that yeah it was something
about like is it a story or just an
opinion piece no i think i saw it was a
document from i could be wrong that's
why i'm saying fact check it because i i
just saw it on social media it was
something like
a drug company and they were like it's
not really monetarily wise to cure
diseases we just need to like sell those
these pills let me look it up i'm seeing
from popsci.com we're closer to curing
all diseases than we think
uh they're like curing blindness i mean
we're if we can actually heal the blind
and let the blind see again a lot of
people think they have the cure to
cancer and are hiding it from everyone
oh that's so they have to pay for the
treatment the truth is that cancer comes
from so many different sources there's
not like a single cure for cancer so i
understand the thinking because the the
cost of fixing cancer is extremely
lucrative but did you find it i mean i
found a story oh sure from medpage today
curing patients is bad for business well
yes apparently they say an article by
take him on cnbc goldman sachs issued a
report so it's not not a drug company
that suggested that drug developers
might want to think twice about making
drugs that were too effective
what do you say the potential to deliver
one-shot cure is one of the most
attractive aspects of gene therapy
genetically engineered cell therapy and
gene editing however such treatments
offer a very different outlook with
regard to recurring revenue versus
chronic therapies while the proposition
carries tremendous value for patients
and society it could represent a
challenge for genome medicine developers
looking for sustained cash flow oh
medicine developers looking for cash
flows is it so gross isn't the first
lipo bever still on and has been on for
like 100 years in like a fire house in
new york or something like that wow i
don't know yeah can you pull that up
about that
the the the argument the idea was that
they needed
planned obsolescence otherwise you'd
sell a light bulb and then you'd never
sell another one too effective
too effective well yeah i found the
article from cnbc that says goldman
sachs asks in a biotech research report
is curing patients a sustainable
business model and i guess it kind of
makes sense that it's not which makes us
then ask why yeah 2018 we have it right
here cnbc for a few years just use gene
therapy that wears off and you need to
boost it yeah you need more boosters or
or how about
a two-stage gene therapy the first one
cures it the second one starts it back
up yeah just a perpetual cycle or a
subscription a subscription
how about jesus wait how about it cures
the disease but also gives you a
different disease
that requires paying us like a
one-for-one program yeah that's gay yeah
swap like violence if violence is the
disease then the military-industrial
complex is the is the treatment it's not
a cure it's a treatment because if they
cure the violence then they're no longer
necessary and then we won't have any
reason to fund the military but then
that's the because they're afraid that
violence will strike again that it'll
never truly be gone and they're just
saying with illness illness will never
truly be gone so if we stop making
medicine we won't be prepared when when
a big one comes when an asteroid land or
a comet lands that has a bacterium on it
that causes some new disease that pfizer
wasn't ready for i understand that
living in fear like that i just it comes
to a point where you got to not try and
profit off of the pain and suffering of
humans so
you know i was talking about this
earlier
there is a and the other day there's a
point in history when you look at major
historical moments
like uh
spanish civil war or the russian
revolution or uh nazi germany when
people left
they moved to other countries and
survived
and i i'd always read and ask them like
why did your family flee what made them
realize
and you know nazi germany obviously
being the obvious one because of how bad
things got
they say things like the demonization of
these groups and we were like they're
targeting us but then the question is
why do people stay
and a lot of people stayed thinking it
could never happen and it wouldn't get
worse
and so i was thinking about like crystal
knocked right you're familiar yeah uh
broken glass yeah tell me
elevator pitch i'm familiar but in case
people don't know
people went around smashing up jewish
jewish jewish businesses it was like in
one night in germany nazi germany um i'm
not i don't know the full historical
details other than the general idea it
was in one night yeah yeah
there was yeah it was a pattern that
went on for weeks but it was one
specific night crystal knocked yeah
night of the broken glass that was like
lived in infamy because it was this
horrible night that
the country it was sort of like a
rubicon moment where it's like you guys
just crossed a major line that's going
to be impossible to come back from and
then it just de-escalated into
everything that nazi germany became it
escalated yeah the country de-escalated
that's a better way to word it so
you know i've read about people who said
like when that happened they were like
we have to get out of here
and then there are a lot of people who
didn't and it's like when something like
that happens why didn't you get out yeah
they weren't activated socially that's
for sure those people had no idea what
was going on no i think it's because we
have the gift of hindsight yeah so i'll
give you an example um aoc
comes out and fabricates a story about
january 6. that the cop someone knocked
on her door and said where is she
where is she
and she's like i'm hiding in the
bathroom and i thought this is it i'm
gonna die or whatever she said i don't
know
that story happened an hour before
anyone had breached the capitol a full
hour she had no idea however in
hindsight she knows most people don't
know the details of the day all they
know is people stormed the capitol so if
she tells this story it sounds like this
thing happened
when we read history and we read about
kristallnacht and things like that we
think
well how could they not have seen it
coming yeah only because we know what
did happen
today
i don't mean to imply that what's
happening now is identical to what's
happened in nazi germany or anything
like that history doesn't repeat it
rhymes there are similarities
take a look at anything that's happened
in the past couple of years and ask
yourself why you haven't fled
because you don't know what lies ahead
and so for us to look back on history
and know what the end result was we'd
say clearly at that point i'd get out
would you would you really any of you
maybe after i don't know billions of
dollars in damage when a when a
marxist political faction
ransacked this country from the biggest
cities of small town when we have quotes
from a guy who said there was fighting
in his building and he called the police
in new york and they said sir the city
is under attack what would you have us
do
when we saw
riots in almost every in almost every
major city
two billion dollars was the insurance
cap on the damage 30 plus dead and
everyone says is this right
maybe
it will become something worse and then
i wonder if in 50 years people will look
back at the summer of love and say
why didn't they get out when that
happened when when you had black lives
matter an identitarian
marxist organization
smashing things up organizing
destruction
they they thought everything was fine
well i'll tell you this a lot of people
have already fled to mexico we read that
story we thought it was funny
yeah a lot of people are going to el
salvador max kaiser max kaiser
prominently and stacey herbert have gone
to el salvador because they're huge
maximalists for bitcoin and that they've
adopted bitcoin as a national currency
in el salvador el salvador yeah yeah el
salvador
and uh like einstein fled the nazis
einstein fled like what early 36 33 or
35 yeah way way early so that's just a
question i have i mean so we're now at
the point
where
the department of justice under one
political faction
has just raided the home
of the
the front runner of the rival political
faction
several members of his his
administration have been arrested
they have now seized the phone of an
active member of congress
like at what point are you like hey
we're kind of in the thick of things
where usually in history we learned
about the people who survived or the
ones who fled i will say
many people don't flee because they're
like this is my country and i will not
let it collapse that's me man i can't
you know we live in california and so
it's california is where everyone else
will be in ten years i mean you're from
new york same deal um any of these big
blue kind of metropolitan progressive
authoritarian strongholds
the california lifestyle at this point
is so blatantly not in our favor that
it's like
if you're going to stay it's because you
have to feel a special sort of
conviction to stay so i don't blame
anyone that's left to texas that goes to
a red state and sets up shop there good
for you it makes sense for us though
it's like man there's there's there's
something holding me here that i can't
leave and in the same way in the united
states it's like we're it's gonna get
worse before it gets better i i don't
this is our country i can't leave no
matter where you flee you run into more
problems anywhere you go yeah geez you
see the way they have people new zealand
the way they handle lockdowns in
australia kicking people's doors in and
el salvador have their own problems
right that i don't think we want to deal
with you know when we're talking about
all this mexico is doing pretty well
i've been thinking a lot about fleeing
and like where would i go what would i
do but i think what's happening is the
united states is freaking awesome and
the state's control is really an awesome
part of why but people are fleeing but
they're fleeing states yes it's it
that's what the that you see the people
they got out early they got out last
year they got out when coveted
that sign of people losing their
allegiance to their state in their local
area though i wanna i wanna definitely
indication
uh
germany if that's an example is what
roughly the size of texas or comparable
smaller a little smaller than that i
think
um we're a big country yeah when the
summer of love happened
we did get out
we we left the south jersey suburbs and
came to west virginia western maryland
and west virginia right so i literally
was like i'm getting out of this place
right so this is crazy there's a couple
reasons why people wouldn't leave
first of all because they don't have the
money to do so like right now i don't
have the funds to back up and move to el
salvador i have no idea where i would
work or what i would do if i were to do
that and the other reason that people
would not leave the us and ostensibly
some of their states is that there is
nowhere else to go and i know that like
steve hilton stays in california because
he thinks that maybe he can save it and
he has people who agree with him uh i
have heard that much of california is
not insane crazy or not right they're
orange county they're like insane right
there's some actual conservatives over
in california because there are a lot of
people there there are a lot of reasons
to stay in the u.s and i feel like this
is just something we're going to have to
go through i don't know what else to say
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there